[Musique]
c'est presque devenu un bruit de fond
qui perturbent une nouvelle fois la
place de l'indépendance
il annonce un raid aérien et appelle la
population du centre de kiev à descendre
aux abris le centre qui pour l'instant
tient bon
pourtant les russes sont aux portes de
la capitale et sur plusieurs fronts au
nord-est la région de brovary est en
proie à de lourds de bataille c'est par
là que passe l'autoroute principale
menant à kiev les soldats d'ukrainiens
doivent donc absolument en garder le
contrôle
d'autant qu'une grande partie est déjà
tombée aux mains des russes
en cinq jours les chars ont avancé de
plus de 80 km
non on n'a pas peur m'a fait mais pas
payé je sais qu'on nous défend on n'a
pas peur
je n'ai pas peur de mourir j'ai de
l'amitié pour mes enfants et mes
petits-enfants je n'ai peur de rien
j'ai été militaire pendant l'époque
soviétique
l'otan est une organisation puissante
alors pourquoi elle a peur de défendre
l'ukraine
autre offensive russe au nord ouest ici
aussi les combats sont incessants les
villes de boudhha rosto mail et ir pin
résiste difficilement poussant les
habitants à fuir c'est à pied qu'il
traverse cette rivière sans savoir où
aller
un prêtre orthodoxe leur donne la
bénédiction
regardez ce sont les cadeaux qui sont
envoyées du ciel ce sont ces stupides
russe qui tuent des civils
au sud-ouest de la capitale les chars
russes aussi ne sont pas très loin alors
la population se prépare
on est des civils de la défense
territoriale on n'est pas préparé à des
attaques contre des chats mais on
combattra les troupes au sol
on a 26 kalachnikov calibre 5,45 mais il
n'y en a pas assez pour tout le monde
de toutes parts la capitale ukrainienne
est donc en cercle et son centre a déjà
été vidé de la moitié de ses habitants
voilà il ya l'ouest